speaking of looking our best dietitian
mia sin is sharing some ways we can
better nurture our bodies with
nutritious foods especially
as we put an end to the holiday season
check it out
hey las vegas now happy holidays today i
have some tips on how to stay healthy
during the busy holiday season
with some delicious and festive ways to
do so my first tip is to build your
meals around
immunity supporting foods and nutrients
focus on vitamin c found in produce
zinc found in beans nuts and seeds and
vitamin d
found in salmon salmon which is also a
great source of protein
is easy to cook and delicious to eat
here i've prepared the ocean salmon
which is ocean raised chilean salmon and
among the freshest salmon available
direct to consumer
between seven to ten days fresher than
retail all ocean salmon are also tested
to ensure they are free
of micro plastics and heavy metals
served with vitamin c rich broccoli and
a site of whole grains to build a
balanced
immunity supporting meal next i have a
nutritious take on a classic comfort
food
these pizzas are made with bell pepper
crusts a naturally lower calorie
gluten-free alternative to traditional
pizza crust
place on a baking sheet and top with
autumn on tomato sauce which comes in
four varieties including spicy
carrot bolognese and vodka sauce and is
made with veggies in less water which
results in concentrated nutritional
goodness
it's also non-gmo verified certified
organic
vegan and gluten-free available at whole
foods and sprouts
top with shredded cheese and toppings
and bake for 20 minutes at 400 degrees
fahrenheit now it's not the holiday
season without
sweets but you don't have to give them
up completely
just make desserts with benefits these
cutout cookies are made
with only six ingredients whisk together
two cups of blanched almond flour
a half cup of coconut flour and one
teaspoon of baking powder
next add one egg a third cup of maple
syrup and two tablespoons of nativa
organic refined coconut oil
this is a versatile vegan cooking and
baking swap for butter
that's plant-based vegan cholesterol and
dairy-free
and has a neutral flavor so you get the
creamy taste and benefits
without the coconut flavor roll out into
a single layer use your cookie cutters
to cut into cookies
and bake on a pre-greased baking sheet
for 8 to 10 minutes
at 350 degrees fahrenheit finally take
care of little ones by helping to fill
in nutrient gaps
child life has been a trusted children's
supplement brand for over 20 years
they make gluten-free non-gmo children
supplements with no fillers or
artificial ingredients
their immune core essentials including
the new super immune soft melts with
elderberry
work together to provide little ones
with support and protection for a strong
immune system
you can find them at iherb.com on amazon
and at whole foods
now i hope you enjoyed all of these tips
and recipes you can find them at my
website nutritionbymia.com
and nutritionbymia on instagram where i
also share
meal ideas and nutrition tips daily